frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren morgen am Tag
dauert der Krieg in der Ukraine nun
schon neun lange Monate
wir alle begleiten dieses Land seine
Menschen und vor allem die Soldaten im
Land mit großer Anteilnahme und
Sympathie ja mit großer Bewunderung wie
sie diesem brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieg immer noch standhalten
wir haben hier im Haus über diesen Krieg
sehr oft gesprochen wir waren uns in der
Bewertung dieses Krieges als eines
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieges
sehr weitgehend einig und ich hoffe wir
verurteilen heute
gemeinsam auf das Schärfste die
Ausweitung dieses Krieges in den letzten
Tagen der sich nur noch fast
ausschließlich gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung richtet das sind
Kriegsverbrechen der schlimmsten Art für
die sich Putin und seinen Regime
irgendwann vor der Weltgemeinschaft
verantworten müssen
aufschlussreich zu sehen dass ich auf
der ganz linken und auf der ganz rechten
dieses Hauses keine Hand rührt bei
diesem Satz
bei ihnen einer ja
meine Damen und Herren dieser dieser
Krieg hat dieser Krieg
dieser Krieg hat Folgen für ganz Europa
und damit auch für unser Land
seitdem Beginn des Krieges meine Damen
und Herren diskutieren wir die
Notwendigkeit einer wirkungsvollen
Verteidigung unseres Landes und des
NATO-Bündnisses noch einmal ganz neu
jedenfalls hat sich von vielen früheren
Kritikern und Gegnern von bewaffneten
Streitkräften mittlerweile die Einsicht
durchgesetzt dass der Schutz von Frieden
und Freiheit dass der territoriale
Schutz eines Landes offenbar doch
bewaffnete abschreckungs-
sie hat Bundeskanzler
Bundeskanzler haben diese Erkenntnis
versucht umzusetzen mit ihrem Vorschlag
eines Sondervermögens für die Bundeswehr
und der Zusage ich zitiere wörtlich ab
sofort mehr als zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandproduktes unseres Landes in
die Verteidigung zu investieren
wir haben ihren Vorschlag einer
Grundgesetzänderung zugestimmt und bei
dieser Gelegenheit mit ihnen und ihrer
Regierung eine ganze Reihe von
Vereinbarungen getroffen
so sollte unter anderem ein
parlamentarisches Gremium zum
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr eingerichtet
werden in dem laufend über die
Beschaffungsvorhaben für die Bundeswehr
beraten und berichtet wird in der bisher
einzigen Sitzung dieses Gremiums die vor
wenigen Tagen erst stattgefunden hat hat
sich ihre Koalition geweigert den
Wirtschaftsplan für die
Beschaffungsvorhaben vorzulegen die
nächste Sitzung ist jetzt geplant für
den 23 Februar des nächsten Jahres meine
Damen und Herren
wir wissen nun aus den
Haushaltsberatungen auch warum sie diese
verabredete parlamentarische
Zusammenarbeit verweigern entgegen ihrer
Zusage steigt der Verteidigungshaushalt
nämlich nicht etwa auf die verabredeten
zwei Prozent und nochmal zur Erinnerung
sie haben gesagt mindestens zwei Prozent
er singt im nächsten Jahr um fast 300
Millionen Euro Herr Bundeskanzler ich
kann es nicht anders sagen das ist ein
grober Wortbruch gegenüber dem Parlament
und vor allem gegenüber der Bundeswehr
und aus dem Sondervermögen das ja nichts
anderes ist als 100 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden dass wir im Frühjahr unter
großen Zeitdruck den siegesetzt haben
weil angeblich Beschaffungsvorhaben
nicht warten dürfen als wir dieses
Sondervermögen verabschiedet haben
müssen wir heute feststellen es ist bis
zum heutigen Tag nicht ein einziger
neuer Auftrag erteilt und nicht eine
einzige Ausschreibung veröffentlicht
worden meine Damen und Herren ein
solcher Umgang mit ihren eigenen Zusagen
Herr Bundeskanzler und der Umgang mit
unseren Partnern in der NATO und in der
Europäischen Union löst zu Recht
Befremden und erhebliches Misstrauen aus
seit dem Sommer dieses Jahres sehen wir
nun eine erhebliche Verknappung der
Energieversorgung unseres Landes und mit
dieser Verknappung sind drastische
Preiserhöhungen verbunden wenn die
deutsche Regierung darauf rechtzeitig
konsequent und vor allem mit den
richtigen Instrumenten reagiert hätte
dann wären die Preise immer noch
deutlich höher als vor dem Krieg aber
dann wäre es nicht zu solchen
Preisausschlägen gekommen wie wir sie
seit einigen Monaten sehen und ich will
das
einer solchen einer solchen einer
solchen Energieverknappung begegnet man
am besten und es ist ein
also wenn sie schon marktwirtschaftliche
Grundsätze nicht mehr ertragen dann
haben sie offensichtlich ein größeres
Problem mit der Bewältigung dieser Krise
als bisher von uns angenommen meine
Damen und Herren das was wir hier
erleben in diesem Jahr ist
wirtschaftlich ein klassischer
angebotsschock und einem solchen
angebotsschock begegnet man doch am
besten und am ersten mit einer
drastischen Ausweitung des Angebots das
ist ihnen sogar in Teilen gelungen
das ist ihnen beim Gas zu erheblich
überhöhten Preisen gelungen die
Gasspeicher sind gefüllt und für diesen
Winter können wir annehmen immer noch
unter der Annahme und der Hoffnung dass
der Winter möglichst nicht zu kalt
werden möge dass das auch tatsächlich
ausreichend für den nächsten Winter ist
alles offen sind alle Fragen offen und
beim Strom meine Damen und Herren beim
Strom haben Sie nicht nur die falschen
Sachverhalte zugrunde gelegt sie haben
sich ja ausschließlich auf die
sogenannte Netzstabilität konzentriert
siehe Bundeswirtschaftsminister haben
mit ihrem zweifachen Stresstest die
deutsche Öffentlichkeit und damit auch
dieses Parlament ich kann es erneut
nicht anders sagen vorsätzlich und
bewusst getäuscht mit dem was sie hier
an Zahlen vorgelegt haben denn die wir
heute wissen
standen doch wie wir heute wissen er
Habeck standen doch die gewünschten
Ergebnisse in der Leitung ihres Hauses
längst fest bevor ihnen die Fachleute
das genaue Gegenteil aufgeschrieben
haben und zu diesem Fachleuten zu diesen
Fachleuten haben auch Mitglieder der
Reaktor Sicherheitskommission gehört die
ihren Unmut über den Umgang mit ihnen
auch öffentlich sehr klar und deutlich
Luft gemacht haben sie haben er habe ich
und die ganze Bundesregierung zu Beginn
ihrer Regierungszeit einen anderen Stil
einen anderen Umgang ein neues
Miteinander von Politik und
Fachexpertise zugesagt ich muss heute
feststellen diese Zusagen von ihnen
reichen gerade einmal bis zur Grenze der
eigenen Voreingenommenheit man kann auch
sagen bis zur Grenze ihre eigenen
Ideologie
und spätestens dann
spätestens dann ist es zu Ende mit ihrer
vielbeschworenen Toleranz ihrem Respekt
vor anderen Meinungen und Auffassungen
und vor allem mit ihren Respekt vor
Fachexpertise da Pfeifen sie drauf wenn
es ihrer Ideologie nicht entspricht
und dann schauen wir uns dann schauen
wir uns die Liste ihrer weiteren Zusagen
aus dem jetzt langsam zu Ende gehenden
Jahr noch einmal wenigstens in Auszügen
an sie versprechen eine
energiekostenpauschale und vergessen im
ersten Durchgang die Studentinnen und
Studenten und die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner doch sie haben es schlicht und
ergreifend vergessen nichts anderes weiß
sie haben zwergegessen
dann holen sie
dann holen Sie diese Zahlungen an die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner nach und Sie
können bis zum heutigen Tag die Frage
nicht beantworten ob diese Zahlungen an
die Rentner den steuerpflichtig sind
oder nicht was ist das denn für eine
Gesetzgebung die sie hier machen dann
holen sie in dieser Woche
die Zahlungen dann holen sie in dieser
Woche die Zahlungen an die Studentinnen
und Studenten nach und wissen bis zum
heutigen Tag nicht wer dieses Geld denn
überhaupt auszahlen soll keine Antwort
auf diese Frage was ist das denn für
eine Gesetzgebung
sie sagen eine gaspreisbremse zu und
klar ist bis heute allein dass die
Dezember Vorauszahlungen vom Bund
übernommen werden sollen alles andere
bleibt trotz ihrer Beschlussfassung vom
gestrigen Tag im Unklaren die
Bevölkerung weiß bis heute nicht wann
sie aus gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse die Leistungen bekommt
die sie in ihrer Regierung versprochen
haben und dann wollen Sie dieses Geld
aus der strompreisbremse mit den
sogenannten übergewinnen finanzieren die
die Energieerzeuger in diesem Jahr und
im nächsten Jahr zahlen sollen er habe
ich sie sprechen in diesem Zusammenhang
nicht von Steuern und Abgaben sondern
sie sprechen davon dieses Geld müssen
man abgreifen das ist ein Sprachgebrauch
den wir bisher jedenfalls im Steuerrecht
so nicht gekannt haben
wir wissen ja bis zum heutigen Tag
wir wissen ja bis zum heutigen Tag nicht
wo sie sich da eigentlich im
Abgabensystem unseres Landes bewegen ist
das eine Steuer ist das eine Gebühr ist
das ein Beitrag Was ist das eigentlich
was sie da machen mit diesem abgreifen
ich sage Ihnen mal voraus
sie werden mit dieser sie werden mit
dieser bekannten mit dieser geplanten
Abschöpfung genauso scheitern wie sie
mit ihrer gasumlage gescheitert sind nun
kann man das ganze abhaken meine Damen
und Herren
unter dem Stichwort handwerklich
miserables Regierungshandeln das ist
dann ebenso sie können es vielleicht
nicht besser das ändert sich
wahrscheinlich auch nicht das Tragische
daran ist nur dass die Lage für
Millionen von Haushalten und Menschen in
diesem Land von Tag zu Tag schwieriger
wird dass viele Menschen heute am Ende
des Monats nicht wissen wie sie das Ende
des Monats erreichen sollen und das
vielen Unternehmen mittlerweile ja wenn
Sie das Bestreiten dann nehmen Sie große
Teile dessen was im Lande stattfindet
offensichtlich nicht mehr wahr vielen
Unternehmen steht das Wasser bis zum
Hals
verstehen Sie mich nun bitte nicht
falsch auch wenn Sie
sie wissen doch gar nicht was ich jetzt
sagen will auch wenn sie auch wenn Sie
alles richtig gemacht hätten wäre die
Lage kritisch es gibt eben für das was
jetzt zu tun ist kein Vorbild keine
Blaupause kein Regiebuch für das alles
was jetzt in einer so schwierigen Lage
eine Regierung tun muss aber ich komme
noch einmal zurück auf ihre
Regierungserklärung kein Bundeskanzler
vom 27 Februar drei Tage nach
Kriegsausbruch haben Sie von dieser
Stelle aus eine wirklich bemerkenswerte
Regierungserklärung abgegeben sie haben
hier im Haus bis auf die ganz links und
bis die auf ganz rechts sie haben hier
viel Beifall ja sogar stehenden Beifall
aller Bundestagsfraktionen der Mitte
dieses Parlamentes erhalten und in
diesem Augenblick hat sich für Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler ein Zeitfenster geöffnet
sie haben es Zeiten Wände genannt der
Bundespräsident sprach vor einigen
Wochen von einem Epochenbruch aber
bleiben wir bei den be zeitenwände mit
diesem Wort haben sie in ganz
Deutschland eine große
Veränderungsbereitschaft ausgelöst weil
viele Menschen erst in diesem Augenblick
ihrer Rede gespürt haben wie ernst die
Lage nach dem Beginn des Krieges
wirklich ist
und mit dieser Autorität ausgestattet
hätten sie ihr Bundeskanzler sagen
können und ich meine sie hätten sagen
müssen diese zeitenwände ist nicht nur
eine große Herausforderung für uns sie
ist auch eine große Chance eine Chance
verkrustete Strukturen aufzubrechen eine
Chance Bürokratie abzubauen eine Chance
Prioritäten neu zu setzen lieb gewordene
Gewohnheiten abzulegen vorurteilsfrei
alle Besitzstände auf den Prüfstand zu
stellen und neben der Sicherung von
Frieden und Freiheit und das ist die
Hauptaufgabe nur eine entscheidende
Frage zu stellen was müssen wir tun um
in Deutschland und in Europa in dieser
sich jetzt abzeichnenden neuen Welt in
dieser Welt von morgen einen
wettbewerbsfähige Wirtschaft und vor
allem
produzierende Industrie und damit
zukünftige Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten
diese Frage hätten sie stellen müssen
denn dann denn genau darum
genau darum geht es jetzt und in der
näheren Zukunft auch und vor allem wie
können wir uns in Deutschland und in
Europa neben den USA und Asien vor allem
neben China als ein wettbewerbsfähiger
Industriestandort bewähren
China China ordnet den Fortschritt von
staatswegen an
die USA schütten ein Füllhorn von
US-Dollar aus sie nennen das in Flächen
reduction Act und schaffen täglich
tausende von neuen
Geschäftsmöglichkeiten
sie diskutieren und streiten immer noch
um das klein klein ihres
Koalitionsvertrages den hätten Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler beherzt zur Seite legen
müssen um anschließend in diesem Land um
Zustimmung zu werben führen für eine
drastische Reduzierung unserer
Bürokratie für eine mutige Beseitigung
des in unserem Land
einzigartigen Unwesens der
Verbandsklagen und das richtet sich
insbesondere an die Grünen sie werden
jetzt die Geister nicht mehr los die sie
selbst gerufen haben mit dem was hier
jetzt an Blockaden und an und an
entscheidungshindernissen aufgebaut
werden
sie hätten werben müssen für einen
Masterplan Energie der nun wirklich alle
Ressourcen der Energieerzeugung
ausschöpft alle Ressourcen und nicht nur
die die sie gerne hätten aus
ideologischen Gründen ich füge hinzu für
die Nutzung auch eigener
Energievorkommen die wir in Deutschland
und in Europa doch nun mal unstreitig
haben und auch wenn es sich die aufregen
wird ja auch für die weiteren Nutzung
der Kernenergie jedenfalls so lange wie
wir sicher bis wir sicher sein können
dass Wind und Sonnenenergie so
gespeichert werden können dass sie
grundlastfähig sind bis dahin verbietet
sich jeder weitere Ausstieg
und dann
und ich will das ausdrücklich sagen nach
der erneut man muss es leider so sagen
gescheiterten 27
Klimakonferenz die wir in dieser Woche
gesehen haben auch für die Forschung und
Entwicklung aller erdenklichen
Technologien der
CO2-Abscheidung der CO2-Speicherung der
CO2 Wiederverwertung bis hin zu neuen
Rohstoffen und synthetischen
Kraftstoffen die Möglichkeit hätten sie
gehabt das hier zu sagen Herr
Bundeskanzler und das ganze und das
Ganze für eine gesamtheitliche
Betrachtung von Wirtschaftspolitik
Energiepolitik und Klimapolitik für ein
engmaschiges Zusammenwirken von
Digitalisierung und decarbonisierung
last but not least für erheblich
beschleunigte Genehmigungsverfahren
nicht nur bei Wind und Sonnenenergie
sondern bei allen Genehmigungsverfahren
die in unserem Lande notwendig sind und
die für unsere Volkswirtschaft und sehr
sichtbar sind das alles
was alles
wäre vielleicht verbunden gewesen mit
einer Überwindung einer Haltung die in
unserem Land leider immer nur Zweifel
und Bedenken kennt hin zu einer ich sage
Ihnen das doch wie ich es mir vorstellen
könnte hin zu einer Grundstimmung im
Land die trotz oder gerade wegen dieser
Krise anpackt Mut fast Zuversicht
annimmt und daran glaubt dass die
Ressourcen unseres Landes noch längst
nicht ausgeschöpft sind
Herr Bundeskanzler sie hätten alle das
nach ihrer Regierungserklärung im
Februar wenigstens einmal in diesem Jahr
in einer großen Rede sagen müssen einer
Rede die die Menschen mitreißt die
Optimismus ausstrahlt und die die besten
Kräfte unseres Landes mobilisiert in
einer großen rede da wissen Sie wenn Sie
darüber wenn Sie das so lächerlich
finden
dann muss ich Ihnen auf dann muss ich
hier doch noch einmal einen Sachverhalt
ansprechen den ich sonst nicht
angesprochen hätte wenn Sie hier nicht
so reagieren der Bundespräsident hat das
vor einigen Wochen versucht und ich
finde er hat eine bemerkenswerte Rede
gehalten über deren Inhalt und Ziele
kann man streiten aber der
Bundespräsident der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat eine solche Rede
gehalten der Kollege dürr und ich waren
die einzigen beiden Vertreter der
Bundestagsfraktion in diesem Haus die
bei dieser Rede anwesend waren kein
Mitglied der Bundesregierung kein
Parteivorsitzender außer uns beiden kein
weiterer Fraktionsvorsitzender und sie
waren eingeladen meine Damen und Herren
Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzenden sie
auf der Regierungsbank keiner von ihnen
ist zu dieser Rede des Bundespräsidenten
im Schloss Bellevue gewesen ich muss es
Ihnen leider doch sagen wenn Sie hier in
dieser Art und Weise reagieren meine
Damen und Herren stattdessen
stattdessen versinken sie mit ihrer
Koalition im ständigen Streit ihrer
Ressortminister und an einem immer
deutlicher werdenden Vertrauensverlust
der Bevölkerung und unser europäischen
Nachbarn und Freunde in die
Lösungskompetenz und in die
Verlässlichkeit dieser Bundesregierung
Herr Bundeskanzler
der Bundeskanzler vor neun Monaten
hatten sie die Chance vielleicht sogar
die historische Chance dieses Land
wirklich grundlegend zum besseren hinzu
verändern sie haben diese Chance nicht
genutzt und wahrscheinlich werden sie
nach menschlichem Ermessen jedenfalls
eine solche Chance auch nicht wieder
bekommt herzlichen Dank
Friedrich Merz der Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion hat die Generaldebatte
eröffnet hier heute im Bundestag hat dem
Bundeskanzler einen groben Wortbruch
vorgeworfen was das Sondervermögen bzw
den Etat für die Bundeswehr angeht
dessen Größe und dessen Umsetzung und
vor allem handwerklich miserables
Regierungshandeln so hat er gesagt das
wird sich wohl auch bald nicht ändern
sie können es möglicherweise nicht
besser und er wirft den Bundeskanzler
vor eine wie Friedrich Merz sagt
historische Chance nicht genutzt zu
haben nämlich vom Ende Februar an die
Politik der Bundesrepublik der
Bundesregierung anders auszurichten auf
die Notwendigkeiten in vielerlei Krisen